foreign
I would love to hear an argument for why
a citizen of this country who lives in
Boondocks Arkansas or or in a rural
District isn't entitled to an education
as good as literally anybody else in
this country
but instead of trying to address that
concern we're trying to fix the outcome
that's Equity that's what Equity is and
Equity is fundamentally discriminatory
and on the worst most prejudicial
characteristics every time that you try
to jerry-rig an outcome
you're only hurting people and making
them resentful my daughter was adopted
from a country in which
we know that universities discriminate
against people born
in this part of the world discriminate
against them
why should my daughter
be discriminated against for her hard
work
and for playing by the rules she's in an
IB Program
because
of the country of origin of her adoption
we're looking for quick answers to
difficult problems
and that is an injustice to everybody
and it's also profoundly un-American